Professor Langdon
Hammer: Let's see,
last time I wanted to talk to
you about Moore as a woman poet,
as an American poet,
and as a nature poet.
I didn't get very far with the
latter.
I started talking about that
long, really tough poem,
"An Octopus," about Mount
Rainier.
I'd like to go back there and
to work through a little bit of
that poem with you.
I suggested that this octopus
that Moore is writing about,
this mountain,
is at once something other,
something out there,
and an emblem of the power of
the natural world.
And on the other hand,
something that Moore identifies
with: certain qualities of the
mountain – its energy,
its force.
The image of the octopus
itself, the glacier on top of
Mount Rainier,
has, I think,
sort of eight arms,
and that's what she is playing
with.
And I suggested that there's
something octopus-like about
Marianne Moore,
too,
with those long lines that
snake out and seem to grasp onto
all sorts of stuff,
producing this poetry of
collage and multiple voices.
Let me see if I can work
through the end of the poem with
you, from around;
well, there's a long last
stanza, or paragraph,
whatever you would like to call
it, that begins on page 444 at
the bottom, line 161.
Moore is talking about here,
maybe confusingly or
unhelpfully, Greek aesthetics,
while she's also talking about
the creatures and people that
inhabit this place that she's
writing about,
Mount Rainier.
She says on the middle of page
445 about the Greeks--it's hard
to quote from this poem.
It's hard to enter it at any
point because each thing is
connected to the other,
and to make sense of anything
you have to work back.
She says:
Well, how do you approach
nature?
In a sense, that's the great
question of the poem.
Here, the brochure is telling
us, well, we shouldn't approach
it with guns,
nets, et cetera;
we won't be welcome there.
Moore is going to develop this
idea a little bit further.
She says, in a sense,
why bother putting all that
down?
Moore prodigiously includes
these quotations from a hiking
handbook, and then includes
lyrical language like "this
fossil flower concise without a
shiver,"
shifting between these
registers of diction,
and then sees the mountain as,
in that sense,
as some kind of special flower
"intact when it is cut."
And then she calls the mountain
"damned for its sacrosanct
remoteness";
that is, she's saying people
damn this mountain because it's
too high and far and remote to
climb.
"Sacrosanct remoteness":
that's a suggestive phrase.
It would seem to imply that the
mountain was being damned for
possibly what we would recognize
as ethical qualities in a
person;
that is, some kind of eliteness
and some kind of reserve;
in fact, properties that you
might find in an author "like
Henry James's damned by the
public for decorum.'"
Here, Moore makes a strange and
wild association between the
mountain and Henry James,
as if the mountain were somehow
a kind of image of that great
early modernist prose writer,
"damned by the public for
decorum";
that is, damned for his elite
posture, the demands he placed
upon the reader,
and his high level of decorum
in writing.
And then she corrects herself,
she says: "not decorum,
but restraint."
That's what James exemplifies
and that's what the mountain,
it seems, exacts,
too.
She continues,
and now she's talking about
Henry James.
it is the love of [well,
and moving out of Henry James
into a general
principle]
doing hard things [whether it's
climbing the mountain or reading
late James]
that rebuffed and wore them out
[the public]--a public out of
sympathy with neatness.
"Neatness."
She arrives here,
substituting one term for
another: first "remoteness,"
then "decorum;"
not "decorum" but "restraint;"
not "restraint" precisely,
necessarily or only,
but "neatness," a kind of
ascetic quality.
"Neatness of finish!
Neatness of finish!"
she says, she exclaims,
those two exclamation points
following as if,
well, how does she say them?
Is it in a spirit of
exasperation with this public
that's worn out by the demands
placed on them by a certain kind
of writing or by a certain kind
of mountain?
Is she here mocking the idea of
"neatness of finish" or raising
it as a kind of banner and
battle cry?
Now she moves back again to the
mountain.
Relentless accuracy [and
here she'll name it "the
octopus" again]
is the
nature of this octopus
with its capacity for
fact.
She's talking about the
mountain, but the mountain
itself seems now to be the
embodiment of a certain kind of
mind,
a certain kind of imagination
that grasps at and absorbs and
comes to assimilate fact.
And then she will turn herself
over in these closing lines to a
series of quotations that
describe the mountain and do so
with a lyric exultation that
climbs to the romantic "sublime"
and does so in this strange
collage form:
It's an extraordinary kind of
celebration and declaration,
a celebration of the frankly
savage forces that the mountain
both embodies and endures at its
altitude.
And as she does,
she suggests that there are
similar forces of primal
violence and intensity that are
contained and indeed expressed
in the writing of Henry James,
in the aesthetic project of
restraint that she herself
engages in and that she calls us
to and calls "the love of doing
hard things,"
whether that's climbing a
mountain or reading poems.
This closing passage is so
powerful and interesting because
Moore moves from a kind of
writing which is often ascribed
to her or identified with her,
that is, description:
precise observation of the
natural world,
a kind of writing that is
frequently seen as limited in
its ambition and its emotional
power,
but that, amassed here in this
sequence, in fact,
takes on a kind of remarkable
force and lyric intensity.
It makes Moore seem not at all
like the restrained or prudish,
virginal poet that many of her
peers and subsequent readers
have found her to be.
The fastidiousness,
decorum, restraint---these
aesthetic and ethical values in
short are here attached to
powers and intensity that we
don't ordinarily associate with
them.
The volcano,
its whiteness,
that's important:
"the white volcano with no
weather side" because the
weather side of the volcano has
been broken off in an ancient
blast.
The volcano signifies a kind of
virginal force.
It is a specifically female
version of elemental power and
of the Sublime,
of Emersonian self-reliance,
that comes to Moore via Emily
Dickinson, who has her volcanoes
too.
Self-reliance:
by "self-reliance" I mean
Moore's hardy American
insistence on self-sufficiency,
on independence,
and on originality.
And she is, again,
the most radically original of
all the poets we read,
the least like anybody else,
and this, interestingly,
despite her reliance on
quotation as her distinctive
medium.
There's a powerful tradition of
American romanticism that's
present in Moore,
with feminist ramifications.
And it's interestingly in Moore
joined to a modernist and
Eliotic aesthetic of
impersonality,
which we've seen defined in
Eliot's essay on "Tradition and
the Individual Talent" and
elsewhere.
Eliot's modernist aesthetics
were attractive to Moore,
I think, in part because
Eliot's idea of impersonality
was compatible with female
modesty,
with Christian virtue.
Let me turn to another poem,
a poem in your RIS packet,
as helpfully concise as "An
Octopus" is long.
And that's the poem "Silence."
And you'll hear a kind of echo
of the lines I just read.
Another, I think, powerful poem.
We saw Moore correct herself in
"An Octopus," saying "not
decorum but restraint."
Here she says "not in silence,
but restraint."
"The deepest feeling," she
says, "shows itself" in
restraint.
"Shows itself" in restraint:
somehow the very act of
restraint is allied to an
expressive act of
self-disclosure,
paradoxically perhaps.
The keys to our deep identity
are disclosed in some of the
ways in which they are withheld.
This is a theme from one of the
poems behind this poem,
which I've quoted for you on
your handout,
from Longfellow,
from his poem of grief called
"Resignation":
"by silence sanctifying,
not concealing,
/ the grief that must have
way."
Moore's writing,
though remote in form from
Longfellow or Emerson,
for that matter,
or Holmes, another poet we'll
look at later today,
is nonetheless deeply involved
in nineteenth-century American
poems.
Here, the poem's silence itself
seems to be an example of what
it's talking about;
that is, it reveals something
about Moore silently through
what is not said,
or rather through the ways that
what is said gestures towards
what is not.
It's a poem that presumes to
speak or presents itself as
speaking for the poet,
in the first person.
"My father used to say";
well, curiously Moore is really
not in at least an explicit way
speaking about her father or
what her father said.
Moore included in her
Selected Poems notes that
disclose some of the sources
that she was quoting from,
borrowing from,
and collaging.
And this particular poem bares
a note that attributes much of
this quotation to a certain A.M.
Homans, who is,
in fact, a distant relative of
my colleague Margaret Homans.
This Miss Homans,
who supplies most of what's in
the quotation there,
is not Marianne Moore's father,
so she's sort of borrowed words
for her father from another
source.
And yet at the same time
there's real poignancy in this
and an expressive poignancy.
Moore is telling us something
about herself.
She's being silent about the
very early death of her own
father who was therefore,
in fact, a silent presence in
her life, who told no stories to
her and said no sayings,
and whom she couldn't,
in fact, quote in this manner.
"Silence," this short poem,
is at once a modernist poem
that Eliot would have understood
and admired and close to
nineteenth-century poems in its
ethical values and concerns.
It suggests too,
I think, some of Moore's
perhaps ambivalent,
certainly complex relationship
to her male peers:
a topic that I talked about
last time with her poem "A
Grave" in front of us,
which was connected to that
correspondence with Pound.
I also mentioned her
correspondence with Hart Crane
who submitted his poems to her
in her role as editor at The
Dial,
where she was,
in fact, in a very powerful
position in literary culture.
In certain ways,
Moore had a kind of established
authority in that culture that
Crane never had.
Here, she had an important job
picking poems,
editing writing,
reviewing, and otherwise
shaping the tastes of American
readers through this important
magazine, The Dial.
And yet, at the same time,
Moore always has a kind of
marginal and combative relation
to her major male peers that is
suggested in "A Grave" and in
her irritation at the man who's
blocking her view.
When you read Elizabeth
Bishop's memoir of Moore –
Elizabeth Bishop,
Moore's great protégé –
that really wonderful bit of
both biography and autobiography
that I asked you to read for
this class called Efforts of
Affection,
in there you see Moore
interacting with the male poets
of her era in interesting and
comical ways.
Remember how some of them
appear.
Bishop notes the presence of
Ezra Pound in the Moores's
apartment when Moore notes that
Pound had burned the banister
with his cigar.
He had to keep his cigar out of
Mrs.
Moore's apartment,
and this sort of flaming
phallic object burns the
staircase.
Bishop also tells about seeing
a valentine that T.S.
Eliot had written to Marianne
Moore;
Pound with a cigar and Eliot
with his valentine.
And then there's an account of
a reading where Bishop heard
Moore read with William Carlos
Williams who – Williams did
– made "loud" and "realistic"
"sea monster" roars.
All of these are kind of comic,
and yet suggestive,
symbolic representations of
phallic power through display,
imposition, condescension,
et cetera, all of which Moore
seemed to manage to keep at
arm's length through her
distinctive life choices,
which entailed living with her
mother in an apartment in the
Village and then on Cumberland
Street in Brooklyn.
Moore's literary life,
her imagination,
was rooted in this domestic
space that Bishop describes
powerfully and minutely in her
memoir;
a domestic space that had all
sorts of eccentric rituals and
charms, a specifically
female-centered world where
Moore could admit men like Pound
but where mother and daughter
could lead their cultured
literary lives very much on
their own terms,
without any men to answer to.
Moore's poem,
evoked in Bishop's essay,
is a version you could say of
the many shelters that you find,
or shells or protective armor,
that you encounter in Moore's
poems.
She admires,
is always fascinated by,
armored animals and the kinds
of protection they seem to carry
with them.
"The Pangolin" is one example.
Poems are also for Moore forms
of shelter, I would say.
They're spaces in which she
could construct a world,
or parts of a world,
again, very much on her own
terms, according to her own
rules.
Like her home,
her writing was made safe,
habitable, strong,
and pleasurable by virtue of
the limitations that she imposed
upon herself.
This is connected powerfully to
Moore's ethical ideas and to her
feminism.
Bishop writes about Moore in
"Efforts of Affection"
often expressing ways in
which she,
Bishop, as a young writer
chafed under the curious rules
and disciplines of the Moore
household.
And yet, she seems to
understand the power that was in
those rules for Moore.
And Bishop defends Moore's
feminism specifically against
the kinds of attacks made on
Moore or dismissals of Moore by
specifically sixties and
seventies feminism.
Bishop says:
Do they know that [that
is, feminist critics of Moore]
Marianne Moore was a feminist
in her day?
Or that she paraded with the
suffragettes…?
Once, Marianne told me,
she "climbed a lamppost" in a
demonstration for votes for
women.
What she did up there,
what speech she delivered,
if any, I don't know,
but climb she did in a long
skirt and petticoats and a large
hat… [She,
Bishop, continues:]
Now that everything can be
said, and done,
have we anyone who can compare
with Marianne Moore,
who was at her best when she
made up her own rules and when
they were strictest--the reverse
of "freedom"?
She puts that as a question,
but it's not really a question,
is it?
She's really making a strong
defense of Moore and of the ways
in which Moore used rules and
disciplines to exercise a
certain kind of freedom and
certainly to obtain a certain
kind of power.
Moore has her own version of
that statement in that essay at
the back of the anthology called
"Humility, Concentration,
and Gusto."
"Gusto" is the sort of virtue
of, let's say,
energy that Moore approves in
writing and art,
above all, in certain ways,
and she says at the bottom of
the page: "Gusto thrives on
freedom,
and freedom in art, as in life."
And art and life are always
versions of each other for
Moore, "is the result of a
discipline imposed by
ourselves."
"Freedom in art,
as in life, is the result of a
discipline imposed by
ourselves."
I've been talking today so far
about forms of self-effacement
or restraint that one finds,
let's say, fanatically in Moore
where she is impersonal in her
self-presentation,
where she quotes and creates
her own voice by quoting others,
and where she seems to withhold
the first person in multiple
ways.
The most obvious and vivid and
visible form of the rules that
she sets herself is of course
the way these poems look.
"An Octopus" and "Silence" are
very unusual poems for Moore
because they are free-verse
poems.
By and large Moore's poems are
always organized into these
complex syllable counts and the
crazy patterns that they produce
such as in,
well, let's say,
just look at "The Steeplejack"
or "The Pangolin" on pages 447
and 449,
or "The Paper Nautilus," which
I'll talk about in a moment –
poems that have intricate visual
patterns on the page.
They are examples and instances
of Moore making up her own rules
and finding freedom in them.
They are also images of what
she calls in "An Octopus" a
"neatness of finish," you could
say.
They present the poems as
highly crafted almost--not just
visual but almost tactile
objects.
"Ecstasy affords the occasion
and expediency determines the
form," she said about her poems,
again, referring to those two
different moments of composition
that she mentions in her letter
to Pound that I talked about
last time,
where poems seem to come in a
kind of vatic inspiration,
producing a certain pattern
which then she determines quite
consciously to reproduce and
extend.
Let's look at "The Fish" for a
moment.
It's one of the most intricate
and distinctive and strangest,
on 436.
And wait a minute, whoa!
She's rhyming.
This is actually a rhymed poem,
too, something you might not
immediately hear.
But yes, but look at it:
the fish "wade / through black
jade" or "an / injured fan".
This is really adding an extra
twist of the rules,
making the challenge of writing
that much harder and in so doing
you might say,
to quote "An Octopus,"
expressing "the love of doing
hard things."
Remember Pound,
his idea of the image.
He wanted to give you direct
presentation of the thing.
What did he think about this?
Here, you've got poems that are
so conspicuously artificial,
that stress a kind of
discontinuity between form and
content,
and that really present
themselves as arbitrary and
constructed, rather than given
and necessary.
In this way,
Moore is calling attention
formally to the contingency of
all her statements and
utterances.
She's also calling attention to
the fact that these are made
objects and that they are the
record of their making.
They're the record of a motive,
what I call "the love of doing
hard things," or which Moore
just as often might refer to
simply as love.
Let me point us to a couple of
other Moore poems.
"To a Snail" for example,
on page 446,
another short,
free verse poem written in the
two- or three-year period where
she wrote free verse poems,
around 1924.
If "compression is the
first grace of style,"
you [snail] have it.
Compression,
"contractility":
these are virtues,
"as modesty is a virtue," and
they're forms of modesty:
What we value in writing in
style is the principle that is
hid, a kind of animating motive
that informs what we have,
what's there before us,
but which is necessarily in
some sense silent and expressed
through restraint,
as it were.
A compressed style such as
Moore's seems to compress and
contain an important human
motive.
Another poem about the
aesthetics of style that,
again, moves between principles
in art and principles in life is
the poem in your RIS packet
called "When I Buy Pictures,"
in which Moore says:
And then she gives a number of
different examples.
Further down,
she starts to generalize again.
She says:
The shelters,
the objects,
the artworks that Moore finds
exemplary that she wants to care
about,
that she wants us to care about
and that she wants her poems to
exemplify, would be forms of
acknowledgement,
acknowledging the spiritual
forces that have brought them
into being: the principles that
are hid in them,
those forces about which they
are ultimately and can only ever
be ultimately silent.
Those spiritual forces,
they have a kind of energy,
they have light.
They're lit by "piercing
glances into the life of
things."
That "life of things," that
phrase, that's Wordsworthian,
a rich, simple phrase.
She means by it the life of
things.
Those things that have life in
that sense are not merely things
but creations that are infused
with creative force.
Artworks for Moore,
like God's creation,
carry a kind of burden of
acknowledgement to give us
access to and honor the forces
that bring them into being.
The really great poem,
I think, on this theme is "The
Paper Nautilus."
And let me end our
contemplation of Moore with this
poem on page 451.
It suggests a way to understand
the specifically female artist
that Moore is.
It's a kind of shell left
behind that protects the eggs of
the sea animal,
the paper nautilus.
It's a beautiful object and I
wish I had the images of it to
show you.
She begins in this first stanza
maybe a little confusingly by
saying:
In other words,
why does the paper nautilus
make its beautiful art that is
its shell?
Does it do so for celebrity,
money, tea-time fame,
the comfort of commuters?
No, no, none of these things,
none of these potential and
base motives for making art.
No, the paper nautilus's shell
is something else:
The shell is,
first of all,
made not for popular or genteel
reasons.
It is specifically a perishable
because all art,
everything we make,
is perishable;
it is a perishable "souvenir of
hope."
It's such a beautiful phrase,
"souvenir of hope."
It is a memory of our desire
and wish and aspiration for a
future.
This is what the shell holds
and contains.
It's not immortal,
it's material;
it's delicate and perishable.
It carries a memory of desire,
of hope that strives towards
the future, and of a belief in
the worthiness of striving.
It exemplifies the "love of
doing hard things," carries this
into the future.
The shell is maternal,
or the sign of the maternal,
let's say rather.
It is a kind of shelter for the
future.
It carries hope in the specific
form of the creature's eggs.
This, you could say,
is a kind of revision of the
earlier image of female power as
volcanic.
Again, there's something inside
of great power,
but it's another way of
rendering or imaging this power.
And interestingly,
this creature,
like the mountain,
is an octopus,
viewed as if it were a poem or
as a kind of version of what a
poem is.
You could say that the shell
Moore's writing about,
like a Moore poem,
gives birth to images of heroic
action,
and her poems are full of
heroic characters:
some human, some,
many more, animal;
all of whom in certain ways,
like Hercules here,
are "hindered to succeed."
And that's a wonderful and
interesting phrase,
"hindered to succeed."
I think it means "hindered to
succeed" in the sense of held
back or restrained.
But when something is
restrained in such a way,
it is restrained in order that
it succeed;
"hindered to succeed," in that
sense, restrained in order to
succeed, to overcome its
hindrance,
and to overcome its
self-imposed rules and
guidelines or stanza forms in
order to produce the future that
it dreams of.
Ultimately, those eggs,
they free themselves and free
the shell at the same time.
The shell in its freedom is a
model of the poem as a kind of
autonomous object,
a thing that stands on its own
– impersonal,
taken away and apart from the
maker.
It is strong and it's delicate.
It acknowledges and points to
the spiritual forces that made
it or illuminated it.
"The Paper Nautilus" is
actively revising the famous
poem by Oliver Wendell Holmes
that I've given you a copy of,
"The Chambered Nautilus," which
celebrates the maker,
you could say,
and the energy of the maker
that moves on to its ever more
beautiful mansions.
Moore celebrates,
rather, the made object,
because it refers us back to
the process of making,
which is not a process of will
only but a process in which the
will is hindered or restrained,
in which aspiration meets
resistance.
Look at the final lines of the
poem, they're very beautiful.
The shell is described as
having:
…wasp-nest flaws
of white on white, and close-
laid Ionic chiton-folds
And there she's seeing the
white shell as if it were a
Greek marble.
And it puts her in mind of the
Elgin marbles that decorated the
Parthenon:
The shell is ultimately
compared to a horse which has
lost its rider,
whose arms no longer go around
it and restrain it.
Well, there's an analogy
between the horse and an implied
absent rider,
and the shell and the creature
that was once inside it,
and the poem and the poet who
wrote it.
Hope, here at the end of the
poem, is renamed love,
a force imaged,
again, through a kind of
silence,
through its absence,
or rather through the traces of
its continuing presence,
which are the traces that we
see in the strength and beauty
of the object which is,
I think, ultimately the
difference between silence and
restraint: that is,
love is present in the poem.
It's not merely silent.
It's present through its
restrained expression.
And what remains in the poem,
in the shell,
and in the Parthenon horse is a
kind of acknowledgement of the
spiritual forces that brought
these objects into being.
Well, we will go on and talk
about Moore's great peer,
Wallace Stevens,
next week.